[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN: Welcome
to part three
of our series on using G Suite
APIs for student developers.
This is developer
advocate, Wesley Chun.
Previously, we discussed how
to use G Suite REST APIs.
Now, we'll switch gears
to show you a higher level
way of accessing those APIs.
We'll switch from
Python to JavaScript
and drop all the security code,
as it's automatically generated
for you by Google Apps Script.
So what is Apps Script?
Well, I think of it as
another Google secret.
But it's actually not
a secret, nor is it
well kept, since it's been
out for over a decade.
It is JavaScript.
But instead of using
REST and HTTP with OAuth,
you use built-in objects
to talk to Google APIs.
Also, you don't have to
write the OAuth code,
because it's automatically
generated for you.
Now while it is
server-side like node,
it's more like using JavaScript
as a programming language,
rather than for a synchronous
event-driven web apps.
Now a one liner describing
Apps Script looks like this.
It's serverless, meaning no
VMs, because we host and run
your code.
It helps automate
repeated tasks,
extends the functionality
of G Suite editors,
connects to non-Google
Cloud products,
like maps, analytics
and YouTube.
And lets you access
external databases
or other online services.
Now let's get started
with a Google Sheet.
It's got many functions,
but are there any magic ones
that only Sheets has?
Well, how about Google Finance?
It's a great way to
pull up the latest stock
price on your favorite company.
Cool, right?
Well, we'll come back
to functions later.
But for now, let's code Sheets
without using a REST API.
Is that possible?
Yep, can do.
Just pull down the Script
editor under Tools.
And here's your Hello World.
A one-line JavaScript
application
that writes Hello World into
the upper left cell of a sheet.
You know, A1, look,
Ma, no OAuth code.
Yet the prompt still appears
when you save and run it.
Now, the output is as expected.
Check the video for a
longer Apps Script intro.
Now back to magic functions.
Here's another one,
Google Translate.
Now those are cool, but they're
Google products, right, Finance
and Translate.
Well, what if I wanted
to write a function that
checked today's Bitcoin prices?
Well, that function
doesn't exist.
But using Apps Script, you
can create custom functions.
Here, I'm calling one
of the many Bitcoin APIs
out there to get today's price.
Check out the sample
code if you get a chance.
And whoo whoo, I've just
created my own custom function.
Now, what can we do with this?
Well, instead of Hello World,
we've got a real piece of data
now.
Happens to be the address for
the Google New York office.
There's also a header
row, so bear in mind,
we need to read cell A2.
Now here's a four-line app that
does something kind of useful.
Like before, we access
the Sheets active sheet,
but instead of
writing to a cell,
we read the address from it.
But we can also pass that
address to Google Maps
and ask it to create a
map with a pin or a marker
on that address.
Finally, we can
call the Gmail API
to send this map to
my friend, to tell
him to come to the
Google New York office
to meet me for lunch.
Check out the video
for more details.
Now, where can you go from here?
Maybe your sales team needs
to visit several customers
in New York.
Or perhaps you
manage a book club.
Well, create a custom
map for members
coming to the next meetup.
Now don't forget, Maps also
has walking and public transit
directions, all accessible
from Apps Script as well.
Now, we've shown
how you can create
custom functions and
Sheets bound scripts
using Apps Script.
What else can it do?
Well, if you've ever
heard of add-ons before,
they're also powered
by Apps Script.
Add-ons let you extend the
functionality of Google Docs,
Sheets, Slides, Forms and Gmail.
It also powers App Maker, Ad
Scripts and Google Data Studio
community connectors.
Now, let's look at add-ons,
starting with Slides.
Ever want to make a progress
bar for your decks to let you
and the audience know
how much is left?
Well, slide bars are not
exactly native to presentation
software, but we
can build an add-on
that extends the functionality
of Google Slides.
Here's the progress bar code.
It calculates how many
slides you have in total,
then creates relatively sized
rectangles on each slide.
Check out our blog posts
and video for a deeper dive
into this sample.
Next, let's say you're a busy
working professional going
on a business trip.
You want to get reimbursed for
your airfare and hotel, right?
Well, for that,
you need to create
what is called an expense
report for your manager.
But since you get
all of your receipts
in Gmail, why can't you do
the expense report there?
Well, you can with
the Gmail add-on.
Here, you can see that
we're kind of in Gmail,
but let's give you
the whole picture.
Gmail add-ons show
up in the right nav.
Ours does expenses,
so we picked an icon
that looks like a receipt, or
sort of looks like a receipt.
One awesome bonus
with Gmail add-ons,
is that they run
on web and mobile.
Meaning you don't have to
write two versions of your app,
and they work
seamlessly on both.
The only difference is that
the add-on icons show up
on the bottom on mobile.
Now, the add-on extracts the
relevant data from the receipt,
like the date, the
amount, the vendor,
then pre-fills in and
pops up this form.
All you do is supply a
link to Google Sheet.
And once all of your expenses
are logged successfully,
you'll have a sheet with
all of your expenses,
which you can export
as a PDF and send
to your manager for approval.
Cool, right?
Well, check out the blog
post and video for more info
and code snippets.
Now that you know how to use
Apps Script and G Suite REST
APIs, join my colleagues
for the next set
of videos demoing
medium-sized apps that
do cool things with these
G Suite developer tools.
This is Wesley Chun from
Google, and thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]